[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui on va parler de
légumes et je voulais tourner cette
explication en extérieur ou en ce moment
et il fait pas très beau ce même un ton
complètement déprimant nom n'est pas
d'abord parler de la météo alors c'est
parti et limay solution au final je
tourne dans ma chambre d'hôtel à rouen
je sais pas trop ce que ça va donner au
niveau de la lumière je vous rappelle
qu'il reste plus que cinq villes pour
voir le spectacle après ce sera trop
tard pour vraiment à leurs otages
il reste nice la suisse à champéry
confiance à donnery moret sur loing et
nantes pour deux représentations mais la
deuxième est quasiment complet pour
gagner mon trophée des cent mille
abonnés ya quelques temps j'ai créé une
énigme pour ça et cette énigme il y
avait des indices qui traînait déjà dans
d'autres vidéos on va tous reprendre
point par point l'énigme en elle même je
vous la remet ici comme ça si vous
voulez la faire il est encore temps pour
le plaisir de la faire en fait je vais
détailler les points un par un comme ça
si vous bloquez quelque part vous pouvez
arrêter de regarder la vidéo une fois
que vous êtes débloquer essayer de
terminer seul jeu vous détaille de la
vidéo énigmes de 30 secondes au tout
départ il ya marqué trouver les bons
chiffres indices dans la vidéo du 8
avril
dans la vidéo du 8 avril si on regarde
et bien il y avait des petits flashs
subliminaux à zéro minute 0 secondes de
cette vidéo on pouvait voir apparaître
fibonacci début et à 8 minutes fibonacci
fin ça c'était juste un guide pour vous
permettre de trouver où est-ce qu'ils
étaient placés les flashs subliminaux et
combien il y en avait entre 0 et 8
il n'y a que 1 2 3 5 de la suite de
fibonacci donc ça voulait dire qu'il
fallait choper le mot à l'intervalle une
minute deux minutes trente minutes et
cinq minutes et surtout qu'il n'y en
avait que quatre ça permettait d'être
sûr et certain d'avoir tous les maux
vous avez également de la description de
cette vidéo un lien vers une page de mon
site internet où je parlais de l'effet
de ce trou pour vous pouviez télécharger
d'ailleurs ces fichiers pour le mettre
sur votre téléphone et le tc sur vos
amis ceux qui ont eu la curiosité
d'aller voir descendre en bas de
l'article sur stroupe ont pu lire la
phrase suivante si un jour vous tombez
sur une énigme penser à chercher la clé
de décryptage cacher la description
d'une clé cachée
la réponse est dans la question cela
veut dire que dans la description de la
vidéo se cache la clé est dans la
description en elle même de la vidéo
toujours il y avait un indice brut avec
marquez vie je n'ai pour ceux qui
connaissent pas dit génère si on inflige
nerfs sur google on tombe directement
sur les explications de ce qu'est un
code de vigenère c'est un cryptage assez
complexe pour des messages secrets qui
fonctionne avec une clé heureusement
aujourd'hui il ya plein de sites qui
permettent de décrypter les codes du gnr
si vous avez les mots et la clé ça peut
crypter et décrypté dans les deux sens
il ya plein de sites
puis pour ça il ne manquait une plus que
donc la clé il fallait trouver l'accès à
la clé du code de visionnaire elle était
extrêmement simple il suffisait de
regarder la description de la vidéo en
question et de prendre la première
lettre de chaque phrase
et si on prend la première lettre de
chaque phrase ça fait mentale vlog avec
un s ça c'était le petit piège donc vous
aviez mentale blog avec un s ça pouvait
sauter aux yeux parce que toutes les
lettres et en majuscules donc en
décodant avec la méthode de vigenère et
la clé mentale blog avec as les quatre
mots vous aviez pris aux intervalles de
fibonacci ont trouvé gauche gauche
droite gauche
dans la vidéo au moment où s'affiche
donc trouver les bons chiffres en fond
il ya toute une séquence avec des dvd et
des chiffres en dessous j'ai gdg des
chiffres en dessous et c et c est bien
de gauche gauche droite gauche
ça fait un peu des coques de rétro
gaming ça fait de gauche gauche droite
gauche
ggd je sais exactement lundi ce que vous
allez trouver en dessous de gdg était
marqué 17 12 et justement que nous dit
la suite de la vidéo en ligne
elle nous dit comparer l'énigme donc
c'est ça vous compariez le gauche gauche
droite gauche avec tout ce qu'ils
avaient à l'écran et vous obteniez 17-12
ou 1702 j'ai déjà cramé la suite de la
réponse des et la question suivante dans
l'énigme était quelle photo de mon
instagram correspond à ces chiffres là
et si on va sûrement maintenant on peut
chercher une photo où il a marqué 17 12
enfin 1712 en gros mais il y avait quand
même un piège ster que tous les chiffres
qui étaient sur le fond avec les mauvais
code les mauvais indices correspondait
aussi à une photo ça c'est mon petit
côté pervers donc la photo concerne avec
17 12 c'était celle ci là où il ya
marqué complet et la suite de la vidéo
énigmes était calé la ville associée
donc si on regarde la ville associée
c'était paris la suite de l'énigme vous
renvoie encore sur une nouvelle vidéo où
il faut chercher une suite de cinq
chiffres une séquence de cinq chiffres
avec la petite précision que c'est à
l'intérieur de pi à la toute fin de
cette nouvelle vidéo indices on pouvait
avoir quelque chose à l'envers assez
rapide
je trouve que ça sautait aux yeux et si
on le retourne et on pouvait lire lundi
suivant la troisième ligne est dans la
description encore un indice il y avait
toujours un indice dans la description
là c'était la statue à un épi ce qu'il
fallait comprendre c'est qu'au moment
précis où la statue de la liberté
apparaissait dans la vidéo il fallait
regarder la troisième
ligne 2 pi mes papilles n'importe où
n'importe comment
c'était un tee shirt de piques j'avais
avec une chemise et à ce moment précis
de la vidéo j'avais fait en sorte que ma
chemise s'arrête précisément pour avoir
une entrée et une sortie de chiffres sur
la troisième ligne du tee shirt
on pouvait donc lire 9/7 1-6 neuf et ça
c'est la séquence qu'il fallait trouver
avec le jeu de mots la statue en épi en
fait c'était pour la statue de la
liberté et qui au moment où elle
apparaissait à la vidéo il fallait
regarder la troisième ligne de mon
t-shirt la vidéo énigme elle nous dit
ensuite la ville plus la suite de
chiffres sans majuscule et sans espace
égal le mot de passe le mot de passe et
donc paris 9 7,1 6,9 à ce moment précis
vous aviez quasiment fini de résoudre
l'énigme puisque dans la description de
la vidéo énigmes jeux vous envoyait sur
une page de mon site internet où j'avais
créé la fin de l'énigme il y avait dix
pages possible où vous pouviez cliquer
pour terminer ça mais ces dix pages et
est protégé par un code secret le code
secret céder donc paris 9 7,1 6,9
là où ça se corse et c'est que lesdits
page s'ouvrait avec le même mot de passe
donc vous n'aviez pas l'assurance d'être
sur la bonne page en ayant le mot de
passe pour ça il y avait un indice à
trouver la vidéo énigmes me disait la
chose suivante
dans la dernière vidéo indice une phrase
vous indiquera plus tard le bon choix
dans la vidéo un lis je vous expliquais
que dans la vidéo en elle même se cacher
une phrase entière une phrase qu'il
fallait que vous trouviez et je disais
d'un petit air malicieux pour la trouver
il faudra en montrer le plus donc on va
montrer plus solidaires pas les lire la
description ensuite je disais le premier
mode cette phrase commence à
l'alternance et je terminais par dire à
très bientôt dans le futur ciao à très
bientôt dans le futur faisait référence
à un retour vers le futur évidemment
dont j'avais trois figurines au dessus
et l'alternance avec ce geste c'est
parce qu'à un moment donné dans la vidéo
doc et marty s'inverse sur mon étagère
c'est ça le début de l'alternance y
avait marqué qu'il fallait entendre
quelque chose et voir quelque chose ce
qu'on entendait c on n'est pas c'est à
dire qu'à quatre minutes 21 et sept
centièmes en entend qu'on n'est pas et
la deuxième chose elle se voyait c'était
le mot silencieux donc on n'est pas
silencieux et on n'est pas silencieux
c'est la phrase clé pour savoir où
cliquer parmi les dix pages possible sur
le site ça va je vous plains pas trop
donc en cliquant sur la page on n'est
pas silencieux ont tapé ensuite le mot
de passe paris9 7,1 6,9 et on avait le
formulaire où il y avait juste à
répondre l'eurocorps et 2
18 minutes après la sortie de la vidéo
quelqu'un a trouvé la réponse à l'énigme
et la personne donc qui a eu le record
qui a été la plus rapide elle s'appelle
lorànt et à l'habitat paris lauranne tu
habites même dans le xxème voilà je ne
donne pas plus sur toi mais pour que tu
puisses te reconnaître vous avez été
exactement 331 à trouver la bonne
réponse
donc bravo et vous avez été plus de 4000
à participer en tout et la double bravo
c'est à dire que c'est pas très grave ne
pas avoir trouvé
l'important c'est de s'être challenge
est de s'être stimuler pour essayer de
résoudre quelque chose d'assez complexe
en fait c'est pas très compliqué dans le
sens où il est pas des calculs
incroyable affaire mais il fallait
vraiment la réflexion tester des pistes
chercher des pistes qui n'était pas très
visible pas très évidente il ya aussi
beaucoup de fausses pistes
donc bravo de l'avoir fait maintenant
sur les 330 et une personne veut en
tirer une eau à hazard silicon.fr
valeurs minimum un bal au maximum 100 le
nombre d'éléments a sélectionnés par
tirage
un seul générer et le résultat c'est 40
de la ligne 43 puisque la première ligne
elle comporte ce à la ligne de 43 qui
est donc ici et c'est lorik et c'est
lorie qui habite dans le 94
alors je sais pas trop comment je vais
monter le tirage au sort parce qu'il
faut pas que je dévoile des infos
personnelles
loric du 94 bravo comme tu es dans le 94
c'est pas extrêmement loin de paris je
vais t'envoyer un mail et si tu veux on
se rencontre pour que je t'offre le
trophée et on fera une petite vidéo
qu'on mettra sur mon compte instagram et
si vous qui regardez la vidéo vous
suivez pas mon compte instagram
prenez le temps de me rajouter ça me
ferait vraiment plaisir c'est fabien
olicard tout attaché c'est pas un compte
certifié parce que j'ai pas de
certification installé un petit compte
pour l'instant qu'à 7000 abonnés mais
vous pouvez me rajouter c'est un vrai
plaisir
alors il y avait aussi deux autres
vidéos indices dont je n'ai pas parlé
dans la vidéo énigme la dernière qui a
annoncé le jour de sortie de la vidéo
nîmes 1 600 heures de sortie pour être
au taquet avant tout le monde et une
autre au milieu de tout ça qui
comportait un code
je sais pas si vous l'avez trouvée je
sais pas si vous avez trouvé à quoi ça
sert
mais ça je vais le laisser en suspens on
rappelle il ya mon livre qui sort le 18
mai qui est déjà en précommande sur
amazon à la fnac chez votre libraire
préféré
on trouve également quelques extraits à
droite à gauche je vais vous mettre un
lien de la description je sais pas
encore si je ferai une vidéo dessus ça
dépendra un petit peu de son jeu
peut-être une ans
en ont répertorié enfin on verra ça et
j'ai les internés truc à vous dire
vraiment j'espère que vous êtes encore
là en photo a dû lutter dès le départ là
les deux dernières vidéos que j'ai fait
elles sont allées dans dans les
tendances youtube donc ça ça fait
toujours plaisir mais surtout je voulais
vous dire un truc ce sont des vidéos
avec des vignettes très classique des
titres très classique donc j'ai cherché
à analyser pourquoi elle était allée
dans dans les tendances et parce
qu'elles sont vraiment pas pour le coup
sexy une [ __ ] à cliquer comme comme vous
dites à tout bout de champ ben en fait
c'est simplement avec la masse de pouce
que vous avez mis l'avant dernière vidéo
il n'avait plus de 40000 là je crois
qu'il y en a plus de 15000 sur la
dernière
merci en fait parce que c'est aussi une
manière de valoriser ces fameux titre et
vignettes qui sont pas pu ta clique vous
vous récompenser ça et ça les met dans
les tendances et c'est aussi comme ça
que vous maîtrisez vous aussi le game
bravo à vous et merci à vous et à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]